LINAN CHEN: Hi everyone.
I'm Linan.
Welcome back to recitation.
In recent lectures, we
have studied the properties
of the determinant.
And we also derived the
formula to compute it.
Today we're going to
put what we learned
into practice by considering
these two examples.
So we want to find out the
determinants of these two 5
by 5 matrices.
And as you can
see, matrix A has x
along this diagonal, and in the
first four rows, y to the right
of x, except for the last row.
And zero entries
everywhere else.
And matrix B also has
x along this diagonal
and y everywhere else.
Before starting, let me
help you review what you
can do to compute determinants.
Of course, you can
carry out elimination
to transform your original
matrix into upper triangular
matrix.
Or you can use this
big summation formula.
Another choice would be
you can do it by cofactors.
Namely, you can expand
your original matrix
along any row or any column,
and then the determinant
is simply given
by the dot product
of that row or that
column with its cofactors.
Why don't you pause the video
now and try to work on them
yourself.
Whenever you're ready, I'll
come back and show you my way.
I hope you just had some
fun with these two problems.
Now let's look at them together.
Let's look at matrix A first.
As you can see, there are a lot
of zero entries in matrix A.
So perhaps you don't need
elimination to introduce more
0's.
Furthermore, we observe
this pattern of A,
and you notice that if
I cover the last row
and the first column, so
if this column and this row
are not here, what is left
over is simply a 4 by 4
lower triangular matrix.
And similarly, if you
cover the first column
and the first row, what is
left over here is simply a 4
by 4 upper triangular matrix.
This is telling
us that we should
calculate the determinant
of A by the third method.
So we should expand along
the first column of A,
and we calculate the cofactors.
Let's do it now.
So determinant of A,
is equal to the (1, 1)
entry of A, which is
x, times the cofactor
of that spot, which is the
determinant of the leftover 4
by 4 matrix.
And it's upper triangular,
so its determinant is simply
given by x to the power 4.
Plus, the only other
nonzero entry in that column
is the y at the very bottom.
So you put y here.
And you multiply
y by the cofactor
of that spot, which is the
determinant of the leftover 4
by 4 matrix again.
In this case, it's
lower triangular
and its determinant
is y to the power 4.
So I have a y to the power 4.
But not quite.
In principle, there
should be another factor
here indicating the sign.
And the sign in this
case, well because the y
is the entry in the fifth
row and the first column,
so this factor
should be negative 1
to the power 5 plus 1.
And of course, it's just 1.
So the determinant
of A is simply
equal to x to the fifth power
plus y to the fifth power.
Did you get the correct answer?
Well, the determinant
of A is not too bad,
because A has a lot
of zero entries.
Now let's look at the
determinant of matrix B.
I have another copy of B here.
So B also has a very
clear structure.
It has x along its diagonal,
and y everywhere else.
But in general, B does
not have any zero entry.
So perhaps our first step should
be carrying out elimination
to introduce zero
entries into matrix B.
Of course, you can do it
by the regular routine.
You start with the
first row, find a pivot,
and eliminate the second
row and the third row
and so on and so forth.
But in this case,
there's a shortcut.
If you compare two rows
that are next to each other,
for example, if we compare the
fourth row and the fifth row,
you notice that they have
a lot of entries in common.
And they're only different
at these two spots.
So imagine if I subtract the
fourth row from the fifth row.
So if I do the
following operation--
so I subtract this
row from the last row.
Then the new fifth row
should become the following.
So this row will become 0,
0, 0, y minus x, x minus y.
You see, just by this
simple operation,
I have introduced three
zero entries at once.
And it's similar with the
fourth row and the third row.
They have common entries
here, here, and here.
So you subtract the third
row from the fourth row.
You update the fourth row to
0, 0, y minus x, x minus y, 0.
Again, three zero entries.
And same thing happened to the
second row and the third row.
So you subtract the second
row from the third row
and your new third
row will become 0,
y minus x, x minus y, 0, 0.
Finally, you subtract the
first row from the second row,
and then you update
the second row
to y minus x, x
minus y, 0, 0, 0.
Let's keep the
first row unchanged.
So I'm going to copy here.
All right.
By row elimination, we have
introduced many zero entries
to matrix B. Is
there anything else
that I can take advantage of?
Let's observe the pattern
of this new matrix.
As you can see, in each row,
you have two nonzero entries,
except for the first row.
And they're only
different by a sign.
So if, somehow, you can figure
out a way to sum them up,
you will get even
more zero entries.
So let's do it.
That's going to involve
the operations on column.
So here is how I do it.
I'm going to keep the
last column unchanged.
So the last column is
y, 0, 0, 0, x minus y.
What I will do is I will add
a copy of the last column
to the fourth column.
So this is what I'm going to do.
Add one copy of the last
column to the fourth column.
Now the new fourth column will
become 2y, 0, 0, x minus y, 0.
As you can see, by doing
this, I have killed this spot.
So I have introduced
one more zero entry
into my fourth column.
If you continue, you may
want to add the fourth column
to the third column.
Let's see what will
happen if you do that.
So if you add the fourth
column to the third column,
now what should appear here is
2y, 0, x minus y, 0, y minus x.
But in this new third
column, you still
have two zero entries,
which is the same
as the original third column.
So although you've
killed this spot,
but you've introduced
a new nonzero entry.
So is there a way that we
can kill this spot too?
You may have noticed that if you
add a copy of the fifth column
to this column again, then that
spot will have been killed.
So let's do it.
If I add this
column to this one--
I'm going to just
update it here-- then
the first entry
should become 3y.
These are unchanged.
And the last spot becomes 0.
It reflects here
as you are adding
a copy of the fourth column
and a copy of the fifth column
to the third column.
Now you've got the idea.
And you continue.
What do you do with
the second column?
This time you will have to add
a copy of the third column,
a copy of the fourth column, and
the copy of the fifth column.
So you update the second column
to be 4y, x minus y, 0, 0, 0.
Eventually, what you will
do to the first column
would be you add everything
to the first column.
So a copy of each.
Then the first
column will become--
so I don't have
enough spot here,
so make it here-- x plus 4y.
Then everything else is 0.
This is fun.
And the result's really nice.
This is wonderful
because this is simply
upper triangular matrix.
Now you tell me: what
is the determinant of B?
The determinant of
B is the determinant
of this upper triangular matrix.
So you simply multiply
everything together,
that's x plus 4y times x
minus y to the fourth power.
So I hope you enjoyed
these two examples.
Maybe your method is
different from mine,
but at least these
two examples teach us
that you can be flexible
in combining methods
in calculating determinants.
Thanks for watching,
and I'm looking forward
to see you soon.